it raises a lot of questions about the
kid's competency yeah it's
not great um and yeah he's uh yeah i
mean look he looks like a [ __ ] he looks
like he's on crank
i mean the kid looks [ __ ] cranked the
[ __ ] out let's listen to him
campaign topic and when asked in june if
you've been tested
um for cognitive decline you've
responded that
you're constantly tested in effect
because you're in
situations like this on the campaign
trail but please clarify
specifically have you taken a cognitive
no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
but i mean i'm so forward looking to
have
an opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
there could be plenty of time and by the
way as i joke with them you know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental fil
my physical as well as my mental fitness
and uh to uh you know to make a judgment
about
who i am god it's so bad
it's like actually it's more painful to
watch that than
anything anything donald trump has ever
said or did and i'm
i know we joke around a lot on the
podcast like you know
obviously like even my crazy trump
friends know that trump says crazy [ __ ]
but it's like that is to me i'm
witnessing a man
who should be in an old age home try to
run for president
yeah what the [ __ ] was that yeah
it's really rough is it bad is it really
bad watching that v
um it's painful i wouldn't say that it's
as bad as what trump has done but
definitely very painful yes so but it's
just one of those things where it's like
what the hell i mean
he can't debate donald trump it's not
gonna work
for some reason the simulator's got a
really good sense of humor right now
it's a dark sense of humor but really
good
they have us kind of living in between
sophie's choices
it's like you go outside open the
economy up everyone gets the rona and it
spikes
and the hospitals are overrun uh you
don't
open up you close it down the ronin
numbers go down but our economy crashes
you vote for donald trump you got a
[ __ ] megalomaniac absolute [ __ ]
narcissistic animal run in the world and
if you vote for
uh joe biden you got your grandpa who's
clearly on the runway in a speed jet is
it a speed jacket i mean he
may in public fully in front of the
nation
yell or racial slur or yell something
like that he may do it
and because he's an old declining
cognitive man but here's the thing
okay i genuinely believe now truly my
heart of hearts believe at this point
i'm not a conspiracy guy although check
out conspiracy cuties patreon.com slash
play rich voice
um i genuinely think that now there
is a global elitist thing that's going
on where trump and biden and obama and
everybody else have just been pawns
and there's a this global thing that
happens because
if the democrats truly wanted to win in
a landslide and they
truly want to change obviously they
would not pick joe biden it's
clear as day they would not pick joe
biden but they're staying by their
choice to pick joe biden
for a reason that's above our heads i
don't think they want donald trump
to lose for some reason and they make
believe they do
or this is the media controls a lot more
than we think about and they know the
ratings will be closer
because you really don't know who's
going to win as if they just paraded it
out some hotshot democratic candidate
that would clearly cut crush trump
nobody would watch the debates nobody
would care so i don't know what the
reason is
but it's almost like i i i'm paying
attention and i'm just like there's no
reason that this man
should be leading should be the
democratic candidate
it's clearly obvious that he should not
be the candidate
but and it's not about his political
views it's about
he's cognitively can't do it so why are
they doing it i don't understand
is there a reason is there anything that
you see yanni is there anything
that you see that i'm missing like how
do you see it
i see something why i i see
my best friend just put the illuminati
on notice
on notice and that's a little segment
called chrissy long days
that's crissy long days and i don't know
what's going on but i
guarantee you that either the conspiracy
cuties
or alex jones will get to the bottom of
it
i i just don't know what else to say i
mean muffin chops
do you do you have any idea
why joe biden would be the candidate
like is there anything that you can
think of
as a smart man with a really
large loaf yeah i don't know they're
probably just
gonna collect them and then kill them
okay so that's it so maybe it's the
point is
we're gonna put joe biden in as the
ultimate puppet and then
get him out eventually but but he
actually may not beat donald trump like
i so i don't get it
like you can have your political
opinions and say i didn't like john
mccain
i didn't like bush i didn't like clinton
i i don't like obama
okay but they're all competent
politicians
this man is he's incompetent he's
talking about cocaine
he said cocaine you can't sing cocaine
don't mention cocaine come on man i mean
you're asking me
really brother i look forward to the
breaks with you
and foreign and then you say come on man
like how many times you're going to say
come on man you think that's getting you
the black vote what are you talking
about
no the guy is going come on brother what
are you doing it's obvious you're
[ __ ]
you're insane he's obviously has it's
obvious cognitive decline um it's really
sophie's choice babe i mean
it's a real fun one the simulators are
going like this right now
hercules i mean look we are very very
smart
members of our patreon you know fam
they're so funny
because of how funny they are i know how
smart they must be
and i'm really asking like can you write
on the community board
why is joe biden the democratic nominee
just
tell me something i don't know
i don't know why he is even on there
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild